okay so this talk is Pender's from the
inside I think probably quite a few of
you were out Dundas talked before an
introduction to pandas this talk goes
much more on the internals of how pandas
works so we can see exactly why it's
memory efficient and fast and so that
will help us write code using pandas
that is efficient now first of all just
to introduce myself I work at JP Morgan
an American bank in London a full-time
Python developer currently I am what's
called a front office developer I run
technology for trading gold silver
platinum and palladium in the
commodities business and I'm about to
move to the equities trading part of the
bank where I'm leading a new team on
data and analytics engineering and
Python and pandas will play a big part
in the tooling that we will use there so
first of all for those that have just
come in the slides have a fair amount of
detail on them and you'll get the most
out of this if you can download the PDFs
of the slides from my github repo and
follow along as we go the link to the
github repo is also in my description of
the talk on the conference schedule so
the goals for today is to look a bit at
the foundations of pandas is built on a
combination of Python and numpy and also
the data frame aspects of are and we
will do
relatively simple piece of analysis the
the topic is going to be sports
statistics the analysis is not very
complicated but we're going to look
quite deeply into it to see exactly
what's going on underneath the surface
in tax so we'll look at data frames
slicing data frames how indexes work and
doing group buys all the standard things
that we do when we are doing analysis
using pandas we'll understand a bit more
about how the syntax works what's going
on we'll see which operations are fast
which operations are slow some of them
very unexpectedly fast or slow and we'll
understand
why exactly that is this will help give
us a good intuition for how pandas works
and so that we can then still write code
that will work efficiently and
effectively as we scale up to bigger and
bigger problems now this part of the
talk will take about an hour and then
the last half hour we'll look at
something that I've called big pandas
which is using a library called desk to
do distributed data frame calculations
now I think probably many of the people
here that have been doing scientific
programming with Python will know about
bumpy and that's used to get high
performance through Python operations
and efficient memory usage and we'll
just look a bit at the difference
quickly between Python and numpy to see
why that is on the left side here is a
representation of a normal Python list
of a thousand elements and the actual
list itself is made up of pointers to
pointers to each of the elements and
then each of the elements themselves
number is a Python object and these
Python objects are shown with in a box
with a little head thing attached to
them which is what makes them a real
Python object now on the right hand side
the numpy version of this we we created
in this case for integers by using that
a range function the the shape of the
numpy equivalent is quite a lot simpler
we have the same sort of pointer to
describe the the array of data but then
the actual data itself is you can think
of it as just being one contiguous block
so whereas in the python case we had a
thousand different elements all of them
as individual objects with types and a
reference count and everything else that
python needs to work on the numpy side
that's much simpler now to understand
the memory usage differences of these we
can define a function the shorthand gso
to get the size of get the size of an
object in Python and we can see for
various types of plain Python lists the
relevant sizes so an integer itself is
24 bytes an empty list 64 bytes in our
list of a thousand elements we need to
take both the list structure itself plus
the elements in the list and that gives
us a total of 37 thousand bytes but for
an array list in Python that has a
thousand elements in numpy if we do the
same thing we define these as four bit
integers and we can pull out some
parameters for the structure of this
array from from the numpy object and
it's full
is four thousand bytes so you can see
straight away by using a numpy array
rather than a Python object for
representing the same data we have used
one-eighth the amount of memory so that
that shows that numpy is far more
efficient than - when we representing
objects of homogeneous data now size in
bytes is one thing another thing that
matters when we are doing processing in
pandas on large amounts of data is how
fast it is and we'll start just now with
with comparing the speed of Python and
numpy and then see how that gets used in
in pandas if we are taking a list of
elements in python and add them up it
takes ten milliseconds maybe you think
that's fast maybe you think it's slow
but review used to programming and go or
or C++ or something you think it's very
slow but ten milliseconds is what it is
if we do the same thing in numpy then it
takes a tenth of that time and that's
calling the numpy native function sum on
the array if we do it in a rather naive
way of calling there Nathan that the
native Python function on the array it
actually takes fifteen times longer than
the plain Python and the reason for that
is that in order to sum all of the
elements of the array Python needs to
pull out the four bytes of memory from
numpy and then wrap it into a normal
Python integer object and attach the
reference count and object type to it
and then it sums it all up and then
discards it so it's very inefficient and
it's quite slow
but you'll see the difference here is
more than a factor of a hundred and this
is a theme that we're going to come back
to several times during this talk with
pandas where if you do things the right
way it will be super fast if you do
things a slightly ineffective way maybe
a dumb way you could describe it then it
will be under time slower and we don't
want that now if we extend our picture
of data to two dimensions then the the
kind of picture you might draw in in
Python is of a list of have a list of
lists for numpy it's actually much
simpler we just have one contiguous
array of data and the description of the
array just points to the start of that
now that shown just here if we want to
we can reshape this array so this is
what a one-dimensional array we can
reshape it into a two-dimensional array
here and what we actually get is a new
header describing that array but it's
pointing to the same data so we've
effectively created a new array but
doing zero copying of the underlying
data and that's sufficient and we'll see
over and over again that numpy tries to
do the pendous tries to do this type of
thing to see how this actually works in
numpy we can take our original array and
the second array and then maybe also
create a third one here by taking every
every third element so in this slice
syntax here we start at the third
element we go to the end and we take
every third one and then we can look at
the info function on these arrays in
numpy
and it will tell us various things about
them so we can see that for the the
three arrays they have quite different
shapes because of the way they've been
defined 24 elements in one dimension 3
by 8 and a second or something with 7
elements in just one dimension 4 for
this third one for the contiguous flag
says whether these elements are next to
one another in memory or not and you can
see where we have jumped through every
every third element that's flipped from
through to false the the data pointer
the info you can see how the first two
arrays are actually using the same data
in memory so by creating that that array
it was it didn't have to copy the data
just create the new array header
structure so that was very fast in the
case of the third array then it didn't
copy the data but instead the pointer is
to the fourth element in the array of
the third element in the racer and and
so creating all of these as fast now
the next thing that we're going to need
to bring from mumfie into pandas is a
number of different expressions for
indexing maybe I should ask who here has
has used numpy for scientific type
calculations okay so roughly about half
of people so so you know what I'm
talking about here
so these expressions for indexing numpy
arrays should be very familiar to you
even if you don't know number because
they're modeled on the standard syntax
for slicing a list in Python we can we
can pull out
a single object or a single row from a
two-dimensional array so using a scalar
index so we pull out a whole row we can
take a slice with the subset of columns
here we can pass in a set of row
integers list of integers here which are
used to pull out our specific columns
from here the first fifth and seventh
columns and that's actually equivalent
to the tape function here when we come
to look at indexing in Pender's we'll
see that what pandas is doing on the
underlying data in a panda's data frame
is effectively this take operation we
can be bit more sophisticated about how
we specify that we can use a boolean
function like this to pull out the rows
where the boolean function is true and
we could also use this on the left hand
side of an expression to an assign the
value back into the matching elements of
the array and we'll see that this works
exactly the same kind of way in pandas
so basically that's all we need to to
take from from mumfie - to understand
the basis of pandas but now we're going
to look at how it's all put together to
create the overall package that that
makes pendants so easy to use and is the
reason why it's it's become so popular
so pandas is now about about eight years
old I think eight or ten years old and
was originally developed for use in a
hedge fund
so where's McKinney designed that hedge
fund call IQR for doing a lot of the
type of analysis that you need for doing
financial calculations a lot like
the the ease of summarizing data that
you you might get in Excel you might get
in our it has the easy syntax the Python
has but also brings together they're
much faster calculations speed and
memory efficiency of numpy now when we
look at pandas if we go to go to the
pandas package open a Python command
line and do import pandas as PD the
normal way of importing pandas and if we
then do dot Eve safely in ipython
notebook or and Jupiter and then hit tab
to tab complete it will get a list of a
whole lot of classes and methods so here
are some of the top level classes in
pandas the the three at the top data
frame series time series you'll use all
the time in your everyday everyday
analysis there's a number of types of
index that you'll be using you just may
not realize that you're using them
explicitly and then as we sort of get
further down this list we get to more
and more specialized types of classes
that you you won't really know about if
we go deep into the internal of pandas
then we'll see things like block
managers and join units and blocks and
things like that so who here is sort of
a block manager okay
well we'll be covering block managers so
this will be new to everyone as well as
all of these in internal classes inside
numpy we also have a lot of functions a
lot of methods on all of these classes
so one of the design philosophies of
pandas at the start was to
to make everything easily discoverable
so all the functionality is there at the
top level of the objects to understand
data frame dot and hit tab and you'll
get something like 425 methods it could
be very hard as a beginner to pandas to
really know where do you start there are
so many different ways of doing things
well first of all there are so many
things you can do then for each of them
there are several generations of api's
that have been used some of them are
closer to numpy some of them are more
high-level and the functionality is
really really broad so it can be quite
intimidating trying to figure out
exactly what you you need to do and one
of the aims of this tutorial is to help
you navigate through the parts of that
that you really that you really do need
one of the consequences of all of this
is very big namespace for pandas and I
think it's about two hundred thousand
lines of code at the moment is that it
gives you a lot of functionality most
things that you want to do you can do in
a few lines and pandas the problem is
it's not always obvious which few lines
of pandas you need to do that and you
can spend a very very long time trying
to figure that out and certainly I found
when I started using pandas but it felt
at the beginning the learning curve was
really steep steep in the good sense in
that then a small amount of time you can
actually accomplish quite a lot but
after that it felt like it wasn't so
smooth and in some ways it felt like the
more that I learned about pandas the
less I was able to accomplish where I'd
be able to do certain things quite
easily and then the one next thing from
that that feels like it should be really
easy turns out to be impossible now
indexes don't join or you get these
weird warnings and and so then usually
perhaps start to lose faith with and say
maybe I'll be better switch
my analysis back to plain plain Python
maybe you persist and you actually
figure out how it works and you move to
the next stage and and so it keeps going
the pendant is evolving rapidly things
are changing a lot our new functionality
is always being added and there's now
talk of producing a pandas version too
that will simplify a lot of this
historical arm detail and make it easier
both for users and for people building
libraries using pandas at the end result
is this is a bumpy learning curve and
hopefully today we will help smooth out
some of these bumps that occur around
about here now when we do a typical
piece of analysis in pandas the the
steps tend to be very much the same you
want to load the data that you've got
into data frames you then want to
reformat the rows on the column so it
looks a little bit nicer add some
indexes then we'll select a subset of
the rows to do an aggregation using
group by and then we'll display it using
some kind of visualization library so
that it looks good and then maybe
compare it with other data these steps
are very standard so we will now apply
that in a domain that spawning
statistics now how many people here have
seen Australian rules football one two
three okay how three people out of about
I guess a 120 I'm Australian I'm from
Melbourne which is where Australian
rules football started in 1897 and so
that's why I'm using this as the example
for the talk I guess the other reason is
I work for a bank the bank is very
protective about intellectual property I
don't want to do anything that involves
financial data because then I'll get a
lot of question
from people inside about what actually
you saying so sports statistics is okay
now what you're used to calling football
is what I call soccer and I look at the
schools of a soccer game and I think
they're so low they're boring
these are typical scores in a the rules
football game we call a football or
footy
so a typical score is maybe 70 to 120
maybe 140 points the the score is
calculated is actually always shown as
three numbers the first number is the
number of goals the second number is
number of points and the total is you
get six points for each goal and then
one for each behind and there's a data
set that has every football game that's
been played since start of the
competition in Melbourne in 1897 and as
of a year ago it had 14,000 games so
that the data set that we're going to
use is a plain text file like this often
when we use pandas we start off with
data that's a nice CSV file with commas
and we can just load it straight in this
needs a little bit more work
we've got multiple columns for sure we
don't have commas between them we have
spaces between columns but we also have
spaces within columns and we have dots
here and we also have dots there - maybe
confuse things now the difference
between goals and behinds this is this
is what the goal end of a other rules
oval looks like the plain ground is
called an oval because it's an oval
shape and there are four goals here if
the ball goes between the middle two
goals you get six points if it goes
between the the outer goalposts and
the middle one you get one point and if
it bounces off the middle one and goes
in then you get one point and there's a
goal line umpire there who will have a
couple of used to be flags in his hand
to wave when you get a goal two flags or
one flag or behind and then here are the
players and the game involves a lot of
running and jumping you can catch the
ball you can kick the ball you can push
off people's shoulders to catch it and
there are 18 players aside yep the
behind is where the ball goes between
the highest goal post and the next one
so when it goes in there to get one
point I have a video that may or may not
work let's let's see how this goes I
think this will be without the sound
this just shows you how they actually
play and run and jump and tackle one
another and pass the ball with a hand
ball or you can run with it and bounce
it and then he's just kicked at about 50
meters into the goal you see that the
schools here 87 88 3 in essence and in
Collingwood and it's the 4th quarter and
it's just gone over the end of time for
that quarter so it was a very very
exciting finish to that match and
everyone is very happy and severe sir
there's the umpire showing that he got
the goal and just repeating that kick so
this is a stadium that holds 110,000
people so that's that's the Melbourne
football ground okay so this is Ozzie
rules now so that's why I think the
soccer is a bit boring this is a lot
more action in all these rules now from
from this data that we start with we
want to end up with what's called the
Premiership ladder and basically it's a
list of the rankings of the teams from
the
number of points they get for four
points for a win two for a draw and none
for a loss and then also rank them by
percentages for goals for and against
and so that's what we want to end up
with to start with we'll load the data
into a panda's data frame and we can do
this with the read CSV function because
this text is not pure CSV we can use
some other of the settings here to
actually pass it in and surprisingly
enough we can use a regular expression
as a separator here
most people don't know you can do that
if you have tricky data you can use a
regular expression you need to use the
Python engine for that arm and so here
we load it up and it looks like this so
here for the next few slides when I draw
pandas dataframes and going to show the
body of the data in green the column
index in yellow the red for the row
index if we pull out these individual
pieces we can see some of these objects
or some of these classes alluded to
before so there's the index here is a
for the Rose as a range index arm we
don't have to store the individual
numbers for the index sets it's a bit
like a slice the column index is just
the names of of the columns and we can
actually get the values in green by
doing that values here and we get back
in this case an empirical ray of all of
the values there and these converted to
time stamps so that looks that looks
really neat and really simple and let's
actually see how fast some of these
operations are
the difference in speeds here give us a
clue of what's happening underneath now
to get the values for the array the the
the data values here it took 35
milliseconds which is actually really
really slow and we'll see we'll see why
that is in a moment to get two columns
from the array is taking 500
microseconds so that's our 70 times
faster so and that returns a panda's
data frame if we just get those two
columns individually it's actually just
taking two microseconds per column and
so you can see that here extracting a
series from a data frame is really
really fast here we're extracting two of
them from the data frame and that's
surprisingly a lot slower I used to
think that keeping things as a data
frame was the way to go if you wanted
speed thinking somehow it was all packed
together more neatly but actually
operating on individual columns which
are pulled out as a series is is super
fast here if we take just one column we
can we can pull out that column as a
series or we can pull it out as a data
frame by taking an array of column names
and you see that those differ by a
factor of 240 in how fast they are so so
there's there's a something is going on
here to make it actually take more time
to to extract that we'll see why that
might be so this is this is where we
comes into play this thing called the
block manager that no one had heard of
now if we go if we go back here when we
got the values of the array we got back
an empiric or a and the reason why this
is a wreck or a is that these all have
different types some of them are
integers
some of them are date times and some of
them are objects so if we if we look at
the blocks that make up a data frame
then actually we can see that each block
is made up of those individual data
types and they have the underlying block
of homogeneous data so from a numpy
point of view though what we see is a
panda's data frame with columns of
different types is actually three
different numpy arrays each of them
having the same data type three
homogeneous data types and then these
labels around the block numbers and the
block locations they say how the columns
in the panda's data frame relate to the
columns and these blocks so if what
we're asking for is to get say one
column from the data frame what pandas
is actually doing is finding out which
block it is and then using numpy slicing
operation to get that column from the
underlying number table numpy is all
coded in C level code so that's very
fast compared with normal Python
operations there's a couple of other
smart things that pandas does to make
things a bit faster and one of them is
caching lookups of individual columns
and this is handled within the gate item
double underscore gate item function
method on a data frame and we can we can
see this very easily if we're in say
ipython by doing a double question mark
at the end of at the end of the method
name now how many people have used
ipython okay almost everyone so you know
that when you're in ipython if you want
to get help
objects you can do question mark at the
end of it and then if you want to do get
further help which involves seeing the
source code then you can do a double
question mark and this is this is really
quick and easy especially in pandas if
you're not sure how pandas is doing
something you just get the the object
you're operating on the method that
you're not sure how it works the double
question mark and it will show you then
and there exactly what the source code
is so we can we can look into the source
code for get item which Python uses for
the square bracket look up here and we
can go through this and we can see that
there is some code here that seems to
take a fast path there's a there's a
cache of looked up columns from the data
frame and so if we've already looked up
one of the columns and then try and look
it up again then you'll get it back very
very quickly and we can see this by
using the time loop function from a
Python command line to look up a column
in a data frame it gives us a warning
that the first one is slow and the
subsequent ones are fast we can look and
actually look in the cache and see it
there and then if we try time it again
we see how fast the this shows they're
all the same time looking up straight
from the cache so that's one of the
things that pandas users to make pulling
out a series from a data frame quick
suppose you want to select multiple data
frame columns so here we have columns
that are different types so what it's
doing we're saying we want the game
number and the round of the competition
and so what pandas is actually doing is
getting indexer on the columns looking
up the indexes the the numerical index
of zero and two equivalent to those
names and then doing the equivalent of
take the underlying lump you take
function on on those columns and then it
needs to add back the the those of the
column index and then stick on the row
index as well and that that gives us
back this data frame
now pandas tends to use index in a whole
lot of different contexts and it can be
quite confusing what it means at any one
time when it says indexer then that is
very simply just an array of integers
saying which elements you should take
from an array now if we selecting rows
then it operates slightly differently so
if we if we're taking rows then what we
need to do is to form a subset of the
row index to be the row index on the
data frame that we return we need to
pull out the the actual underlying data
using all the reference to that data
using the take kind of operation and
then stick back the column index on the
top if we create this new data frame
here we can see that the columns on the
original and new data frame the column
index they are exactly the same object
so pandas hasn't had to calculate or do
anything different with the columns here
it's just given it a reference to that
other object and no new objects has had
to be created so that's a very fast
operation the range index this was a
rain
index here because they're contiguous
numbers here the the new new range index
needed to be created and that's just
like effectively a slice with the three
numbers with the start and stop so these
kind of select operations the the
operations that need to occur is lookup
the row and or column index to see which
parts of the data frame we need to
return use the block managers to create
the right subset of the data they're
modified the row and column indexes if
necessary and then stick that back in a
new data frame so here are some time
timings for the different parts of doing
this
you can see that if we looking up a
subset of rows from the data frame then
if we use the dot values to get closer
to the underlying numpy objects then
taking the rows here ends up being very
very fast and here this is operating a
hundred percent on the number data and
that's less than a microsecond that's a
the first stage of doing our analysis we
just read in the the raw data we've got
a panda's data frame and we can see that
that data frame has a column index row
index and data that's made up of a block
manager where the block manager has
blocks of homogeneous lumpy data for
each of the different data types you
have a question
you know so arm lock is based lock is
based on labels also yes which which one
of which one of these would be
equivalent to lock so lock is a label
based lookup arm and so a lock that's
looking up labels is going to be slow
because it's got to physically use the
index to see which values match whereas
something that is using eye lock is
using indexes into array so it can jump
right to the correct memory locations
for that so anything involving eye lock
is going to be fast relatively speaking
anything involving lock is going to be
slower so now we're at the the next
stage of the analysis that we want to do
and this involves reformatting our data
into a way that's more amenable to
analysis that the starting point of the
data is here and we'll do a number of
conversions on it here too to get it
like this I won't go into all of the
details here for pulling apart these
these columns using red X's they're
quite needs so you can look at them
yourself but what we're doing is
basically taking the left and right
halves of this table and sticking it
together arm vertically so that we can
then see it from the perspective of
rather than team a playing team B we can
then have it from the perspective of a
team who's playing who their opponent is
and then the scores that are for and
against them
so so here we've
labeled these columns for and against if
that's the score that is for the team or
against the team so it's I won't go
through it in the interest of time I
won't go through all of this about
indexes looking up values are one just
quick point on using indexes to align
things when we add them up our indexes
need indexes of the way that pandas
knows which rows have to go together
when you are merging two objects whether
that's adding them or sticking columns
next to one another you can see here
that if we have two series that have
indexes with different values then if we
try and add them then we have got a gap
where the indexes don't match but also
see how these are changed from integers
to floats so numpy doesn't pendous
doesn't have a way to represent missing
values for integers the way it
represents missing values is with an an
and we don't have Mane's and integers so
that has to be a float so the type of
this column has been changed to a float
in order to what's actually going on
when this is being added is effectively
common index as being formed between the
two then the two series get re-indexed
and then you can add them up directly
element by element I won't actually go
into these joins and mergers that focus
on multi index so multi index is where
we have multiple valued key indexing the
rows of the pandas array and here we
have we have set up our asked to index
these four columns and when we print it
you see that the column names shown one
row higher than the multi index names so
our index is in red these columns are in
yellow and the data itself is in green
and these are shown by the columns the
index here is a multi index and it has
names levels and labels and this is
effectively a more compressed way of
representing that if we want to select
rows from the multi index we see which
elements of which unique elements are
here and then can lookup which of the
numerical indexes match them here and
then bring back those rows and that all
operates very efficiently from the low
level code it's a lot like the way a
categorical series is set up as well
with the unique values and then an index
is saying which one to use now the
reason why we've set it up like this is
that we want to select the data from a
subset of what we have so we want to
take just one year and the data that we
had had the normal what's called the
normal round robin competition leading
up to the finals and it also had
preliminary finals qualifying final semi
finals and grand finals we don't want
those so we just want the normal rounds
of the competition ideally you know we
would just like to be able to do a
multi-dimensional slice like that and
recent versions of pandals have let you
do that there was a bug a couple of
versions ago where it didn't work with
state values but I think that's been
fixed now here are four different ways
we can do this and we will see that the
times for for those different is result
would be split up the whole
data frame by the date and the round
that is being played and then if that's
one of the ones we want to keep then
we'll put that back in our list and then
we'll concatenate them that takes nearly
a second so what we're asking pandas to
do is to take a data frame do all of
this selection of subsets of rows create
a whole lot of smaller data frames and
then merge them back together again
that's a whole lot of work to do and
that's quite slow we can we can do
similar things achieve similar results
to that like this by indexing here is
iterating over all of the rows in the
table now iterating row-wise over a
panda's data frame is something you
generally don't want to do if every row
needs to then be returned as a pandas
object it gets all of these operations
around creating new row indexes
everything is just a lot of overhead
going on that you don't want to do
especially if you're going to ignore it
straight away so don't do this because
it will be slow just like in number you
want to try and do an operation that
will operate on the whole of the table
together here is a much faster way of
doing it where we are just iterating
over the index where that's able to
return values much quicker another
slight variation on selecting the the
values in each of the multi index
columns where we're doing a boolean
operation and arrays of Cruzan false to
get the values we want to return and
then here doing a look-up on the values
that we want to match and that's
actually the fastest by a big margin so
the moral here is try and use this
approach
because it's simpler to write with code
and wherever possible avoid something
that iterates over the rows of a data
frame or that splits the data frame into
lots of sub data frames now this this
function we can also use on the
left-hand side just liking just like in
numpy and so we could set a whole big
chunk to zeros
this explains near interest of time I'll
just skip over this but this is
explaining how the indexing is work is
working to figure out what to return now
having got the subset of data that we
want to use in our analysis we now want
to do some calculations around that and
in we need to get the number of games
played 1 or drawn so that we can end up
with this championship ladder at the end
we saw we've got our data we can set the
number of games played to 1 and that
will create a new column we get this
slightly odd warning and what this what
this means is that pandas is worried
that here we're not clear whether we are
operating on the original underlying
data it's just a slice of the underlying
data or whether we are i want to operate
on a copy of the original data frame and
if we're assigning values back into this
it gives us this warning since we're not
sure whether we mean to change the
original data or not this is this is
controlled by this flag here that says
whether a data frame is a copy of
another data frame and we can avoid this
warning by explicitly making a copy so
that it's not referencing the original
data frame
and then if we add that column then we
no longer get that warning adding that
column is very fast and the reason is it
hasn't actually added it to the
underlying data managers integer block
it's actually cheated and created
another integer block we said we would
have just one data manager block per
type whereas here we have two that are
integers and what happens is pandas
tries to be lazy as you're doing column
operations but as soon as you do
something that needs the whole of the
table then it does something called
consolidation like if we're doing a max
function it consolidates the table and
then that has merged these these blocks
back together again that's why this
operation seems very slow but our so it
seems very fast but that's because the
slow step is is consolidation and that
actually happens as late as possible now
we want to add the number of games we've
got played we want to add one number of
games one and then the number of points
for and then the number of losses as
well here are four different ways that
we can try to add new columns to a andis
data frame and they're all wrong in
slightly different ways so let's quickly
look at them one by one so maybe we
expected to get integer values here but
they've come out of boolean z' here are
we expected to get zeros or ones and
they've come out as Nan's
and here that has actually come out of
zeros or ones as we expected using an
eval function you've probably never used
an eval function in pandas but that at
least gets that right so this is wrong
because it's the wrong data type we need
it to be integers
and then for the the drawers we also
then need to fill their man values where
there are gaps with zeros and then
convert that back into integers if we do
all that then we have this array that
has the indicator variables where we
want them then we can do a group by and
sum them together and that will count up
the number of games one drawn and lost
by each of the teams in the 2016
competition now I said before that group
buy can be slow where is that I know a
couple more slides further back the
weather with that operation involving
group buy and the sub data frames that
took eight hundred and twenty
milliseconds here we have a group by
operation that is very fast and the
reason is that numpy knows that for
certain types of group by operations
it doesn't need to create intermediate
sub data frames so here we don't need to
create a new data frame if we're doing a
sum we don't have to create a new data
frame for every venue and team for some
it can just pull out the values from the
existing array and return the one number
corresponding to the the sum for each so
if we if we do it at the naive way by
splitting our data frame into other data
frames and then summing it and then
concatenate in it is very slow here it's
50 times faster because the sum is going
directly into the underlying data the
explanation of what's going on here is
there's a object created with a grouper
and it
keeps track of where each of the groups
have their locations in the array so
then if you are looking up a particular
one of those it can just grab those
indexes directly and grab the values
using the low level non P operations
to sum them up that's and that's very
fast now the final thing we need to do
to have our table ready for display is
to add percentages and points
percentages is just a ratio of goals for
and against and there's nothing very
special here we can just sort the array
based on that and then we add an index
at the start
well add that and then which is a
position here and so here we have a the
published championship table and what
we've ended up with is something that
looks exactly like that so that's a very
simple piece of analysis typical of the
kind of things that you'll do all of the
time with with pandas but we've seen
that there are certain operations here
that are a factor of a hundred times
faster or slower than other ones and the
reason for that we now understand is
because of the way that the underlying
data is stored as as number blocks the
summary of all the code here the
conclusion for this is young pandas is
great we we know that that's why we're
all here because we want to use it one
of the problems is that there's not just
one way to do things which is that the
sort of price to boots is what Python
tries to have as its philosophy but
there are many many ways to get things
done many old ways many new ways many
bad ways
and a couple of normally good ways as
well and those good ways come from the
core of Anders which is num B so I think
we now will see more about how pandas
actually operates inside how that's
relatively efficient and also seen some
tricks to use inside ipython or jupiter
notebooks to help understand what
exactly is running now this has been a
simple standalone example it's a
relatively small data set just fourteen
thousand rows and once we've started
doing analysis on something that big or
that small then we'll start to ask
ourselves well what happens if we do
bigger and bigger problems how big can
pandas scale up I actually started
writing this talk as a result of using
pandas to try and do drill down for all
of the financial trades that my business
does JP Morgan it was millions of trades
and we were trying to give a real-time
drill down to individual assets making
up those trades the financial
instruments the tenor the date into the
future when when they expire and all
kinds of other aspects and we're trying
to produce a real-time sort of slice and
dice studio for people to use and we
needed it to respond in in real time for
that and had we wanted all calculations
to be done locally on someone's PC and
found that by pushing pandas by
understanding the numpy core of it and
using sensible decisions about data
types we could actually take what had
been a problem that needed to run on a
cluster and
take several minutes to compute would
actually run real-time in a couple of
seconds on on a local PC understanding
how to do that is something that took a
lot of sort of pain along the way in
frustration and the result of that was
me wanting to turn it into tutorial to
help other people that are heading down
the same same track if all you're doing
is problems that involve a few thousand
rows it doesn't matter how you do it
computers are fast enough and everything
will be fine but as you scale up to
millions of rows then you have a very
different set of problems so this is the
end of the first part of the talk and
we'll move to the desk data frames part
next and give you a sense of how
Pender's works if we do calculations in
a distributed way that's in the next PDF
slide if there any just questions now
about this section as I switch over
there's someone here who had a question
yeah
so it it tries to avoid when so look
like it so there the previous talk said
that arm Anders is taking a copy and
I've just said that it doesn't now the
for those many operations as possible
when you are still doing selections from
a data frame then pandas will try not to
copy it will try to use a reference to
the underlying data as far as possible
but then when you reach an operation
that really needs that data to be
consolidated together in in the block
manager then it will then make a copy
because it needs to consolidate that so
there are so it does eventually make a
copy are depending on the operation that
you're doing but you can also just be
operating on the underlying data it's it
gives a warning when it thinks you're
doing something wrong but it's not
obvious it tries to be efficient but
there are traps there yeah so if I'm
reading a really long piece of code and
if I want to test which which part of
code is really taking so much of time so
rather than working on time it function
for each and every piece of code is
there any other suggestion that I could
do so that I'll have an intuition so
this part of code is really taking time
so I have to focus on this one so in
this general profiling code that will
let you see where the most time is being
spent it's I mean this is a really
application specific question as well we
don't have that much time left so I
haven't talked to more after if you
don't mind so
the next part of the talk is to give you
a flavor of what happens if we want to
scale up our pandas calculations to
bigger problems and this is using a
library called desk if some of you have
heard of desk any people heard of it
anyone used it okay so our desk aims to
be a drop-in replacement for certain
aspects of pandas dataframes it operates
in a very different way sometimes that
won't work for you
but if it does then it can give you
benefits of working on much larger
datasets with very few changes to your
underlying code the example I'm going to
use here is American flight data the
on-time performance flight data it's a
monthly data set and each one has about
450,000 rows there was a poster
competition run by the American
statistical Society back in 2009 using
this data and this was the winning entry
that is going to highlight one portion
of it this is a bunch of years showing
the on-time performance day by day
through the year says 52 little columns
there seven days a week each one of
these blocks is a year
you see on-time performance gets worse
in summer holidays gets worse over
winter and then I think here is a I
think probably a recession so our
analysis goal is to produce something
similar to that the the data comes as
CSV files we can read it in using
standard pandas just like this here just
taking the first four rows and
displaying it transposed so it's easier
to
to see on the screen and it shows for
everyday the flight numbers and then for
various aspects of the flight depart to
time take off time delays the number of
minutes taxiing and so on now we want to
do this for a whole range of months not
just one individual month if we read in
one month like this then it's taking
about seven seconds and it's using a
total of seven hundred and forty
megabytes which is quite a lot of memory
so let's be a bit more ambitious we
taking three months and reading those
three end of data frames use read CSV
and then concatenate them and we find
that this seven seconds has gone up to
more than a minute and we're using 2.3
gig now that's that's not great and it's
especially not scalable as we go through
all the different months in this data
set now this raises a number of
different issues one is the data storage
format CSV isn't great maybe something
that's close to a machine format is
better so we'll look at using parquet a
whole lot of other different formats for
that we want to be able to load the data
in parallel the type of calculations we
also want to do in parallel using
multiple cores or multiple machines but
we don't want to put any more work into
making it right and we still want to be
able to do that using Pender's and so
one solution to this is this library
called desk and so if you want to know
what desk means the official answer is
it doesn't mean anything it was just a
short word that wasn't used by any other
project so that's the official word on
it so we can read in with a desk data
frame
we can read in a CSV file we need to
give it a little bit more information
about the structure of the data for that
to work efficiently and then when we
read it in it's actually reading in 18
milliseconds so this is reading in the
data selecting some columns from the
hundred nine columns we've got three of
them we've done a group by and then
we've sum them up and that's done in
eighteen milliseconds isn't that
fantastic that's pretty amazing I think
and that's pretty amazing because it's
not actually doing that there's one
final step in order to get that in
pandas we would have got the answer
there but in desc we need to do one
final step which is to compute it and
that's now taking nine seconds but the
results that we get from that is what we
would expect if we were doing it
straight from pandas and we've done a
very simple calculation it's used one
effectively one line of code and it's
it's been relatively efficient now to
understand what's actually gone on here
when this returns in in just a few
milliseconds is that expressions like
this a best thought of as a task rather
than as a calculation and so the task
here we can visualize the task and we
end up with the dependency graph of the
steps this is too small to read but
effectively this has got the three
separate monthly files and then a
process to read them all in and do a
group by and then it merges the group by
results and then you get your one single
result at the end that's what the the
compute function executes all this and
gives us a result back we do this with
many months we can use wildcards here
and it will find all of them and
automatically produce a dependency graph
and that's
there that's a really really simple way
to get parallelization and if it's we
tell it where the data is indexed so
here one field is indexed and we want
just a particular date range then it can
actually prune the graph before it
executes it so it knows it just needs to
execute this one path and all of that
that part of it can be thrown away so
it's also more efficient in doing
large-scale calculations so so dusk is a
library that we use to do this CSV is
not a great format a better format is
park' and that includes some indexing
information and also stores things with
each column separately so we can set up
well we'll save the data in a park a
format and then read it indirectly like
this we can say which columns we want
with the CSV we're reading the whole of
the file with park' we just get the the
subset of columns and so that's that's
relatively fast doing the group by and
sumit and computing it previously it
took seven seconds to do that for one
month now we can do it on the whole data
set in 300 milliseconds so for all the
different months plot it directly is
matplotlib you do put a notebook and we
can see the number of cancelled flights
by day over a seven-year period and that
that took a third of a second so that
shows the right library plus a good data
format plus not reading in the data that
that you don't need to feel calculation
is far more efficient this example is
selecting a subset of the dates for
doing that and if we visualize the graph
then it's able to prune off most of
what's being read and just returned one
section there and just to try and get
something that looks like the closest of
a example diagram with the shaded heat
map pandas can can now do gradients in
in a data frame and so this is this is
how you set that up very simple to do
and quick and easy so that's a
distributed calculation very quickly
before we finish just show you how you
can monitor the progress of that there
are a number of tools one is a simple
progress bar that has a text thing that
moves along and shows you when the
calculation is 100% complete
it also has profilers for what's
happening over time for the memory
that's used and so on and that looks
like this and in this case we have four
processes running in parallel to do the
parallel calculation and this shows the
various stages that they're going out
through to getting the end result and
the memory usage for that um the it's
got a couple of minutes left won't
really go into what is a dusk data frame
beyond saying it's like a pandas table
with the column structure from from the
from the pandas dataframe and then the
rows describes how the underlying data
is partitioned in the low-level storage
and then it uses that to split up the
calculation with
low level pandas operations the the
tasks themselves are a bit like abstract
syntax trees or maybe s expressions in
Lisp store dispersed Python dictionaries
and this gives the instructions for a
scheduler of which of these tasks to
execute in which order so they're
dependent on other ones as we
implementations or lazy reimplementation
zuv a lot of the pandas methods so that
it can prune the graphs and not
calculate the things that it doesn't
need to and then computing the graph is
effectively running a function to say
get us the answer needed of that graph
there's a scheduler that does that with
different chad euler's that will either
work on on a local computer or in a
cluster and various other distributed
ways but it's it's really nice and neat
it's really simple code actually when
you look at it there's not very many
lines of code there to achieve all that
and if if this can solve your problems
for doing data calculations on a scale
that are a bit too big native pandas
then it can enable you to just keep
working with bigger and bigger data sets
there's some rough edges because it
reimplemented
sections of pandas but it doesn't
reinvent all of it in a lazy way and so
some things are a bit unexpected and
also doing thus tributed operations they
have very different costs so when you
are doing mergers of data or indexing in
wiki ways that can be quite slow that
that's intrinsic to to working in a
distributed way for some of the stuff
that I do at work starting to use this
on a bigger and bigger scale and really
testing out how this will work in
clusters when you have multiple sets of
work going on at the same time so that
that's my next goal with this but some
dozen introductions
dusk I hope that whetted your appetite
to try it for larger analytical tasks
all of the code to do this is there in
the sample notebooks on my github repo
thank you very much
we have time for one little question
um nice talk how does that compare to
flower sorry - to spark for example so
if you have like really big data yeah
very clean so I only think they're
different seasons and their desk tries
to build the whole of the graphs at the
start before it goes
sparkles they're much more pushing
computations further down
I think the yeah in practice I don't
have enough experience with what is
going to work best with each work now we
have about five or so different cluster
technologies that are being used and so
I'll be doing more benchmarking of how
things really do do work differently in
practice and so the desk documentation
does have a bit of a description of the
differences in how the workload is
generated in PI sparks versus tasks if
you want to look at that in more detail